أصبح على دراية بخطة العلاج تقريبًا
كان لدينا واحدة فقط ، كانت عملية زرع
حسنًا ، لقد بدأت ببطء وأكرس ذلك
هنا معنا وهو متأكد
[موسيقى]
لم يتم خدشه على جسد الموضة
الصناعة والظل على
و لكنه أنت سيد واحد كبير
من الحلويات
في البداية لم أكن أعرف حتى ما هو
هذه الدمى لمدة 10 دقائق على تأملات هناك
جلس على كونش الخوف ظهر لي
في البداية حتى كان يعتقد أن يرفض
إذا أحصينا عدد الوفيات
المرضى الذين لم يمروا
زرع لأنه لم يكن هناك
متبرع متوافق طبيعي
34 الف
في روسيا كل عام ، هذا هو الواقع
لا تمر من الروسية المعلن عنها
وحدة المعالجة المركزية الباليه على الحائط
هذا الاسم هناك اسم
ضوء على اختبار إعلان الباب
أجرتها فتيات يبلغن من العمر 10 سنوات
مع عدد قليل من الفتيات اللواتي جربن
نامي تصطحب ابنتها لتقولها إليك
يوصى بالمحاولة
حبل كارينا الجندي في من علاج فرم
ألم بالفم ولكن المثبط يريد المزيد
جماهير البار أو المقاهي وحقول ماري
حول دليل على العلامات والمغذي ل
baida i on karina abo.ua له هياكل عظمية فيها
جاء ليصبح كسرًا
ليس من الواضح سبب تعاملنا معهم
لا يتم علاجهم ، أي ليس فقط إصدار
الساق ليست كسر المرة الثانية فقط
عولج 2 كسر بينما لدينا دم
انها جيدة دون الخروج
دروس بسبب الكسور في المقام الأول كنت بالفعل
لا يمكنك الحصول على جدرانك لك
التماسيح في مكان معنا لم تعط
أنا أشكو ، أنا في حالة صدمة ، لقد قتلت نفسي للتو
امنح كارين ألين كيجانو محيطًا ترادفيًا
قوس قزح قدم ساراتا
ثم لا يوجد سبب
لقد ذهبنا
أو ذهب للعمل لإجراء عملية زرع هنا
في مرحلة ما ، شعرت بذلك
هل هناك خطب ما
لدي 5 أشخاص يظهرون مثل هذه البقع
بدا أن أحد الطلاب يدق ناقوس الخطر وأصبح
من الواضح أن لدينا انتكاسة
بدأت العدوى و
وصل الأنف والفطريات بشكل أسرع من
مناعة من الخلايا تعافى
الدم حتى 3 هذا المعدن
تدير المقبض
الى الخلف
الأطفال ما في الممارسة
تعود تدرك أنها سهلة
وبالطبع
1 سم
العمود الفقري سوف يرتكب خطأ وأفراح فانجا
بدا
الطفل في الواقع لا يذهب إلى أي مكان
كانت هكذا وهناك فرق معك
من العمود الفقري
[موسيقى]
كنا ذاهبون للإشارة
الهند ولكن ماذا تعلمت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بيري لا يخاف
انتهيت من رسم فاليري لإعطاء هذا الطبق بالفطر
ولكن يموت أولغا أكل الشرج الذي كان
عمر او قديم
يطير زنبق ز د لنا محطما بهدوء قطع
الدفع لعربات إلموس.
لكن بالنسبة للانتخابات ، فقد سكب أوكتان سعيد
البولي أميد احتضان الفلسفة فيلم أولي
عناوين
ذهبت إلى مصحة القراصنة لدينا
لمدة أسبوعين هناك لاحظت ما يلي
كدمات على جسدها وأخذت
تحليل الدم العام
تم بالفعل تخفيض العديد من المؤشرات
على الفور
متخصص في المستشفى الإقليمي
وتم قبوله في قسم الأورام
الأفكار باردة بطريقة ما لدينا على الفور
يمكن أن يقال مرض الإنسان
ارتفاع هذا المستوى المنخفض
ثم تتكدس الصفائح الدموية في جميع أنحاء جسمك
الهيموغلوبين المنخفض
وهنا تم تشخيصنا في البداية
مشكوك فيه emule أو الماعز أو فقر الدم
[موسيقى]
وعندما قيل لنا أن الأمر ليس كذلك
ليكوس هو البلاستيك لهم وأنا
الزفير نعم يقول سخيف أننا
هرع البحرية على نادر ما حقا
في الواقع ، لا داعي للفرح ، لكنني اكتشفت ذلك أيضًا
أنه بعد كل ما لدينا الصوتية وجود مثل هذا
شديدة ونادرا ما تكون خطيرة
ماذا تريد ان تذهب الى المدرسة
قليلا لأنه لديه فنجان
[موسيقى]
نفسية أعطيت نفس الشيء
العثور على قسم الأورام منا
لماذا الاطفال اصلع لماذا هم
هناك شخص مريض شخص ما روبرت شخص ما
يبكي كثيرا
[موسيقى]
قال عن الزرع ماذا سيحدث فيها
هذه الخلايا الأجنبية
بعد ذلك سوف تكذب
استعادة هذا كل ما نحن عليه
تحدثت في مستواها الذي تعجبه نوعًا ما
يفهم كل شيء
ينتظر حاليًا أيضًا مانح
[موسيقى]
إضافة آسف روس أنا كذلك نعم
Talma أحب هذه الذباب aedra خنفساء
مصبات الأنهار بينما هو قتال فم فيلم قتال
حسنًا ، حائلًا على الرغم من أنني جدي
تغيرت وقيادة صوفي أطلقت يا
هل هو حقًا سكب ما يصل إلى مليار ك جديد
في فمها
حول
ربما حوالي 25 28000 في السجل
في كيروف في بتروزافودسك في رأيي
حوالي 6000 هناك تسجيل في
سان بطرسبرج
هناك أيضًا بام بام حوالي 10000 بئر ، هنا في
الناقل المسجل لدينا في بلدي 25
في المجموع حوالي 80 90 على ألفا نضيفها
لغة البرمجة
كلهم أموال
[موسيقى]
نص 2 أسطح خضراء بإسم خبراء التجميل
مستوصف فلامبي ختم نقدر بينزا
متلهف، متشوق
أنا مع سيف كامينسكي أوستن الخفيف
الرمال على فيفو
يشتهر صانع الغلايات بأخذها بعيدًا
helsinki لكن فيدال مجرم لكن استمتع
إنجليزي.
العلم السويدي أكثر من الصغيرة في اليوم التالي
في عبيد موسكاو الساحر شلالات توري
المريخ واحد للتخصيب والشرج لأنفسهم
الطريق إلى قوس التبغ من فريتيل السلطة
تقاسم مع الزوجة
و axoft dong king pain hyun sang juan في المنزل
إلى أن حوالي مليون جني المزيد عن الأقدار
تقدم روسيا q2id
مناشي تيدا البراز
الجنس فلدي وقف بركه في حليبي
الطريق من الكرز الأحمر تحت لي
الذهب في يالطا كيمي سوف يحلم بالجنون
الاستياء يعرفون نعم شكل أقواس رأس الفاكهة
لي على يولد لك فقط اترك هذا
المحتوى في هذا يذهبون ساعد في التراجع
ثرثرة بومبي
هنا أقوم بتحويل السقالات إلى بدون طين
تعديل هذه الأبواب نظيفة بالنسبة له
يعطي طعم التمارة والتفاصيل نفسها
لسيسيل - المنزل
asalim زي موحد سلاك من قبل سارة
بالين
makaeva الجديد من مجموعة
[موسيقى]
هذا هو أكثر ما لدينا
بدون
ولم يحرق التصدير
ths والبيض لديك في المنزل
[موسيقى]
الاستياء تجاههم و
وارين حلال كان أكثر ولعا
Liber de la valea تاجر بذلك
[موسيقى]
طلب اسم المدخل الرئيسي
من الغضب
غبي من outta stephanishin
المخاوف لديها ضريبة القيمة المضافة وفي السيارة لدينا التفوق
ويصر على أن الوتيرة ستنطلق بخطى جديدة
المحتوى سواء احتفظت الأرداف بالملف
أنت تقلد ثم لدينا حفلة موسيقية
زجاجة جيدة ، نعم ، شخصيًا ، أنا بعدك ، أنا أتابعك
ألف مبروك التحاقك بسجل المانحين
نخاع العظم
أريد أن أملأك حتى عندما تتغير
عناوين الهاتف أكثر حول أو في وقت لاحق
يجب إبلاغ سجل المانحين
نخاع العظم
لأنه يمكنك أن تصبح متبرعًا في
في أي لحظة ورمي كل من روبينز
براءة اختراع مجانية فيال ماجناني زمان
لحظة في مقابل قيمة في rus a la
فيلم yazal u milked adata لا نعم لدينا
اسم الجدة هو واجهة المنزل
مشهورة ثم مشيت ثريا فريدي
قراءة في رحلة ملء خلفية الأفراد في ألفا
سلام لي مخيط على تنمية التبرع
نخاع العظام بدأت معه بالتأكيد
قصة سقوط الصغيرة بولين هي قصتي
أصيبت زميلة العمل مارينا بالمرض في عام 2014
هي فقط لم تعجبها الدولة
طفل وذهبنا إليه
على الرغم من أنهم كانوا ينتظرون بالفعل وخز وقادونا
القضية الحالية ضرورية منطقيا
فرع منطقة تشيليابينسك
الفريق واضح بعد كل كردستان
تشنج لهم
تعلم تلك الفرصة الأولى 1 على
أن التوأم الجيني يمكن أن يكون
في أي قرية في مدينة أخرى في أي
بلد العالم ولن يكون كافيا أين هذا
ترك التوأم الجيني نعم نحن معه
أولغا
يعتقد أننا بحاجة لرفع موجة
القوة في روسيا لا تقل
حتى يعرفها أكبر عدد ممكن من الأشخاص
حتى يأتي أكبر عدد ممكن من الأشخاص
وهذا هو ما نحتاجه على الأقل
تبرع رجل العمل بالدم
بدأ السهم في اكتساب الزخم.
انضم متطوعون من مدن مختلفة
بعض الناس المهتمين ، إذا كنا
لأسهم المتبرعين لبولينا أكثر من 20
مدن شاركت في نفس الشيء
اليوم العالمي للمانحين
لدينا بالفعل 36 حالة لحية
انضم إلى تعليق الترويج هذا
دقائق يفعل كلا النوعين على الكلبة في 9 سوليرا
كل الجيش الأحمر فأنت في المنتصف
أناستازيا على جوقة كل من روبن
شخصان فقط يفكران في بولينا الحقيقية
أرجونا لديه محرك أماريتو وأحذية إيرينا
زرداري
نهائيات الخريف هذه الأنواع من الكرات
[موسيقى]
سارت عملية الزرع بشكل جيد
بهدوء كنا ننتظر جوابا كان الجواب
تبين أن جسد بولين أقوى وليس كذلك
قبلت هذه الإجابة المطلوبة الآن
زرع نخاع العظام من
متبرع ذو صلة لأننا لسنا كذلك
يمكننا الانتظار
تفعيل التالي غير ذي صلة
جهات مانحة
[موسيقى]
نحن ذاهبون الشر والشارب منطقة dakhadaevsky
هذه قرية أصلية يأتي منها مانحون
نخاع العظم
[موسيقى]
وضع رسلان
هذه الذبابة.
زرافة الكاريبي أشارك تذكرة مع أفيرا
كثير هذه هي الفكرة لديهم
أن العظام تكسر تسحب الدماغ
لذيذ إنها قصة مخيفة
يقول أننا سنخرج من الدم بالفعل
يعتقد أنه يوافق القمامة
آبائنا وأجدادنا
من المعروف أن الجميع يولد ويبقينا أيضًا
سيكون مع العقل أو بدون رفع تردد التشغيل على الإطلاق
سوف يدفن هنا
وبعد ذلك سنسافر سيرا على الأقدام
قرية
هيا بنا نمشي وإلا فلدينا وسيلة نقل لا لا
ستمكن
سأضيف عبارة لتذوق 0 0 متر من فندق الفن
سنوات من روما سوف تندم
التغلب على كوني فيفا ثيلما لينا
يقوم بتدريس روسلان المحلية
مشكلة العثور على متبرعين للعرقية
الأقليات هي المشكلة الكبرى
في الواقع هم لا يصلون لتقديمها في
قاعدة البيانات الدولية والبحث يمكن
تستمر لسنوات وتنتهي بالفشل
من الصعب جدًا العثور على النمط الجيني القوقازي
يجد المتبرع المناسب في أي مكان
فقط ليس في داغستان نفسها
يتم البحث عن الناس داغستان في جميع أنحاء العالم من
وسيط ما سمعته والقائمة
هناك طفل من المتبرع الراحل 2
المتبرعين وجدت في إسرائيل في روسيا
وجدت نفسي دخلت عندما كنت في التسجيل وفي
نسي نخاع العظم ذلك حتى
اتصل عندما طلبوا من kirov
نتفق معه بالطبع نتفق العظام
يتم تأجير الدماغ في الغالب للأطفال
كيروف حيث مكاني أكوام ميروسلاف
قيل لنا فقط أنهم أطفال
لا يقولون لي ما هو عليه
الذين مررت لهم ليس الجنسية ولا اللون
الجلد لا شعر حتى الآن أقول تريد جان
يمكن للمرء أن يتحدث اكتشف في ماذا
فعلت الدولة
سنة أخرى للانتظار
[موسيقى]
اتصلوا بي وجاءوا
في نفس الوقت هي الحماية والمكافأة
اللوائح وتشعر بالمنزل المسكون
مسخ
نعم ، كنت في مسرح هانسو الروسي
قد يسأل عن المواطن
السيارات على وجه التحديد إلى بلا نهاية gns pif
سأخرج في الفناء ، لا أسأل جبال الأنديز فجر
مدينة الآس للمرة الثانية لتشكيل
كرامة
كنت كلاين asus eee pc أنا فجرت الهبوط
مسرح جديد
DSD بدون علم وتحقيق يودع في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
السلطات وقاعة المتبرعين للدرجات
كتل الكابلات مع تي تي تي تي تي تي تي
إحساس الوصول إلى قاعدة البيانات لأكثر من
موقع الدجاج والصور
هذه الأنواع من تقشير إعدادات مثل هذه الملفات
و
لا سمح الله نعم موسع فاشين تايم واحد
م
العنوان الذاتي داش ماجيك و dpk
التقاء المرحلة الأنثوية ومشاركتها
بيت الأزياء المفضل لدي
أمر التسليم الأبيض عداد المسافات ولكن أيضا
مثل هذا النموذج. دعونا نشرب في جيمس هاوس
[موسيقى]
bishtov ومارس الجنس مع هذه السيدة
ذروة هذا الأمين هي خادمة خاصة
دعها تكون معايير مثل هذا الفيديو
التعليمات باستريكين نفسه
عندما تصبح دبوسًا في العالم ، انتقل إلى
بيانات
قدم stepenko رابطة الدول المستقلة التي تشعر بها
مؤتمر سكايب
ستكون الملك سكايب
مؤتمر gdc mhm. المكتب أولا
لدينا مقاتلة فوسو
[موسيقى]
بعد أخذ ثقب في العظام
وأخذوه إلى ديما روجاتشيف في
موسكو للتشخيص لنا هناك
تم تشخيصه
عن طريق سرطان الدم اللمفاوي النمط الظاهري
مخاطر الأرومة النخاعية
لا يوجد علاج آخر غير الزرع
العملية نفسها جرت تحت قيادة جنرالي
تخدير
9 ساعات بدأ كل شيء ثم أنا
أتذكر فقط اللحظة التي كنت فيها
يرتدي هذا القناع وجميع
الثالثة مساء استيقظت بالفعل
من الصعب جدا بالطبع من التخدير
كان . كان هناك القليل الآن بالفعل
لم يتبقى شيء
وصل ميكا في الوقت الخطأ
من الساعة
اقترب منا شاب من
كيروف سجل فيها
كانت لحظة الزرع 25 عامًا
ما عرفناه هو أن التعلم معروف بذلك
في طفل صغير وأكثر كل شيء
كل شيء آخر كان مجهولاً كل شيء كان خرائط
طبيعية بطريقة أو بأخرى الساقين. انه دونالد الضفائر
الموسيقار اقترب من الطفل نفسه
لكنني أعتقد أنه هو نفسه يريد واحدة جديدة
لنرى قبل من خلص ببساطة من قبل
فكرة ولكن جزء منها جيد وخلاق
هذا هو الحال لأنه
لقد تغير ، كان لدينا مثل هذه الشقراء
ولد مشرق الآن هو معنا
في البداية أصبح أسود عندما
الآن هو بني غامق
بشكل عام ، أي سمات شخصيتها
تغير طفيف أي تغيير
الناس هم في الواقع روسيا
[موسيقى]
على اتخاذ القرار المتزايد
واحد
أنت تذوب
هذا جورج
في 100 غرام تقرر
يا إلهي بيتك الذي تمطر عليه عظم
مخ
أنت تستعد لمناهضة الدين
في الواقع ينمو أيضًا
[موسيقى]
Alekhine هم عن الأشياء العاهرة ثم هناك كمين في
تصرف سيبا عالية مخفية
أحصل على نفسي من قازان تتارستان
التحق بالكلية التقنية
تخرج الطيران في السنة الرابعة عشرة
وهؤلاء في هذه السنة الرابعة عشرة في
أصبح أغسطس متبرعًا ، أي
أخذت العظم علبة الطائرة وما فوق
هذه الحقيبة التي جلبتك غيرنا
كتبه شاب يبلغ من العمر 25 سنة
كل شيء آخر ملتصق بأغاني كيروفسك
اتضح أنك ستعرف كل شيء
أكثر والشيء الوحيد الذي قالته اليرقات
ما يحتاجه لينين هو الخلايا الليمفاوية
ويقرر تأخر العربدة في الأعلاف الباردة
انها لينا ديفاس assalatu دومينغو
هيدو
المنزل يو من حافة الهاوية عندما يركبون
فاسولاتا للسيدة جورج إيزابيل أو
إرسال واتخاذ القرار في المنزل ولكن فقط وجبة دسمة
أليس
[موسيقى]
والبقاء معنا لمدة أربع سنوات ومتى
هنا يذهب الأطفال الذين أنت معهم
تغيرت عندما واجهت ذلك
لدينا جميعًا مثل هذه الحالة هناك فتاة
سأل طائرته
في طائرة معجزة
إنها تغذي أريد جرس نفسها
هم الآن في قائمة انتظار وضع هذه الطائرة
اشترى تجميعها
هذا هو ، ألقت اللوم لأنني اشتريت
سوف تجعلك صفراء نفسك أصبحت جيدًا بالفعل
بواسطتك
يقلب عقلك
بعض الماء
[موسيقى]
منع تشاجر الحبوب
ماسيا التصوف
[موسيقى]
الآن هي بصحة جيدة
فقط عمليات نقل الدم بلدي باستثناء هذا نحن
بالضرورة أسبوع واحد مرتين أو مرتين أ
الأسبوع كيف تطلب نفس يقول نحن
نمر على وجه استسلامنا الغليظ
الدم ترى النتائج على الفور
تحتاج إلى نقل الدم أو لا تحتاج و
نقل أو أنبوب كتلة من الصفائح الدموية
أو الدم بالفعل يزيد الهيموجلوبين وكيف
فقط المؤشرات سترفع أكثر أو أقل
يحاذينا مرة أخرى دعنا نذهب إلى المنزل
أسبوع والآن فقط دولة وهنا
يتم دعم عمليات نقل الدم هذه
[موسيقى]
يرمى
لا شيئ
وأنت الرابط هنا ، لا تقلق بشأن كل شيء
حظا سعيدا كالي أيضا ليست المرة الأولى
كورا تستسلم لخطيبي بينما هو خارج
سنأخذ أرزنا الشهير هناك
أنت لا تعرف أصابعك الآن أنت طبيب
أين سيستغرق الأمر
[موسيقى]
يمكن
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حزين بالطبع يزعجنا الزوج
دعا عيادتنا الفيدرالية دعونا نغادر
في الحفلة على الخطة و
الزرع اتصل هاتفيا بالطبيب
رئيس القسم أضعنا و
قالوا لا فائدة
الجهات المانحة المحتملة للقاعدة الدولية
يفترض أن البحث لا يزال مستمرا ، نأمل
ماذا سيجدون
ترى من ورنيش في هذه اللحظة قال ذلك
اللحظة
[موسيقى]